Hi there. Today I'm going to talk about how organizations are evolving their security maturity
and how Burp Suites can support you on that journey. You've probably heard people talking
about things like DevSecOps, security automation, and shifting left. In software development,
a traditional waterfall approach involved four distinct phases. Design, build, test, and deploy.
Many new projects or major updates used to take months or even years to progress through these
phases. Very often, security testing was left right until the very end. The whole agile and DevOps
revolution has transformed software development to use shorter development cycles, automated testing,
and continuous delivery of updates. DevSecOps is about applying the lessons of agile to security
by bringing security testing earlier in the development process. In terms of the traditional
waterfall model, DevSecOps involves shifting security to the left. This axis of testing early
versus testing late is one way to measure the security maturity of an organization.
Higher security maturity means doing security testing earlier, using more automation in security
testing and embedding good security practice through the development process. There are good reasons for
doing all of this. Testing early saves money. Fixing a bug in late testing or even after deployment
can cost tens or even hundreds of times as much as fixing it in early testing. Security automation can
remove the bottlenecks and gates that security can impose in the delivery process, so you can take your code
into production faster. Teaching your developers about security issues as they're coding can help them
to avoid security bugs and write more secure code in the first place. Where do you sit on the security
maturity spectrum? I used to be a penetration tester and I saw all kinds of crazy things, like being
brought in to test a new single sign-on application that was going to receive sessions from an external
system. We arrived on site, ready to test the app, and it wasn't quite ready. They were just bringing
it up, ready for us to test. So they said, while you're waiting, why don't you read the design
documentation? Which we did. On page two, we found a glaring security weakness that was fundamental to
the design. We waited for an hour, the system came up, straight away we were able to exploit it and bypass all of
the security controls. This was a system that had spent months in development and was now supposed
to be ready to launch. All the time when an application was almost ready to go live and security
testing was scheduled for the last minute, we were due to come in the week before on a Monday.
They weren't quite ready, just ironing out a few loose ends. Come in on the Tuesday, still weren't ready.
Went through the week. Can you come in on the Friday and do your penetration test so that we can
launch on Monday? Well, it was supposed to be two people for five days and we only got one day left,
so maybe you can send four people and do a monster day, test six in the morning until six in the evening.
Which we did. And that evening, we were still reporting serious security bugs in an application
that was supposed to go live on the Monday. These might be extreme examples, but this kind of thing
does still happen quite a lot. In fact, most organizations occupy a region of the maturity
spectrum, not a single point. They have different teams going at different speeds or different levels
of security awareness. They maybe have various legacy apps that have to be dealt with in a different way.
Hardly anyone is at the extreme left of doing pure DevSecOps. For most people, that is still an aspiration.
And even if you are doing DevSecOps, there are still good reasons for testing late as well. Maybe even in
production. There are issues that arise from environmental configuration that will only emerge
and be visible quite late on in the deployment process. There are whole classes of vulnerability
which are infrastructure dependent. Things like caching vulnerabilities and HTTP request modeling.
And if your application is a mashup that pulls in third-party code components of runtime, the only
real way to know what is executing is to run the live application. But if you are doing DevSecOps,
then you should expect fewer surprises in your late testing. As well as the security maturity axis,
we can also plot a vertical axis reflecting the size of the team or your organization or the web estates
that you own. The bottom right is the home of traditional penetration testing, generally using
Burp Suite Professional. Pen testing doesn't scale efficiently because you need people to do it.
So it's expensive to do pen testing at the top right when you're very big. Instead, for scanning at scale,
you can use Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. The Enterprise Edition uses the same scanner as Burp Suite Professional,
which is trusted by penetration testers. It has a flexible agent model that lets you scan 10 or 100
or 1000 plus applications. And you can automate and schedule everything. It gives you a clear view
of your security posture and is a safety net that is always running in the background. Scanning at scale is
great. But the most exciting thing about Burp Suite Enterprise Edition is that it can enable you to
shift left and embrace DevSecOps. Enterprise Edition can be embedded in CI so you can trigger scans
automatically from your pipelines. Engineers tell us that security testing can't slow down development,
and the key to that is getting fast feedback. Enterprise Edition integrates with your existing tool chains.
You can kick off scans directly from CI. You can view details of vulnerabilities in your build logs,
and you can automatically file JIRA tickets. Engineers tell us they don't want more audit reports,
and they don't want another portal they have to log into to go and see vulnerability information.
It's vital that security works with and around the existing development tools and processes,
not the other way around. Burp Scanner finds the bugs. It's been battle hardened for over a decade by tens of
thousands of penetration testers. Security teams tell us they can't afford to lose the goodwill and the
attention of their engineers by bombarding them with false positives like you often get from static analysis
testing tools. Burp has extremely high signal-to-noise ratio, so you can rely on its findings without
overwhelming your engineers with bogus issues. Burp gives you detailed evidence for the vulnerabilities
that it reports. You can identify the application function, the entry point, sometimes the line of code
where the vulnerability exists. This lets developers get straight down to fixing vulnerabilities when they arise.
You can deploy Enterprise Edition easily and quickly with minimal setup. This lets your engineers get on
with engineering so they don't have to waste time administering another complex system.
We've seen that most organizations occupy a range of the maturity spectrum, with different teams and
applications moving at different speeds. And as your security maturity evolves, Enterprise Edition can
support you on that journey as you progressively transition from scanning at scale to DevSecOps.
As your security maturity evolves, individual teams and applications will move from being tested late
on a schedule to being tested early within CICD. An Enterprise Edition will give you an overall view of your
security posture, including teams and applications with different levels of maturity. Do get in touch to talk about your
organization's security maturity journey and how we can help. And if you'd like to see for yourself how BurpSuite
Enterprise Edition can help you achieve DevSecOps, please do apply for a free trial on our website. Thank you very much.
Thank you.